t s r
q p o m n l
k j i h
g f e d c b
a we got the alphabet
on
[ __ ]
challenge
going
i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone did we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine
i am shaking in my kitten heels right
now so am i honey you guys sitting to
our left
might be the most iconic duo
to hit the earth honestly now we get
only a short period of time with them
since they live in florida now and i
really don't even know what to expect so
i know you guys are probably wondering
okay we get it introduce your guest
so
today is the moment we have all been
waiting for the listeners have asked and
we have delivered joining us on the
unwax podcast today are two
very important people in our life we
have super supermom businesswoman and
cavapoo extraordinaire oh yeah jennifer
stallone and movie star writer director
and lover of competition reality tv
sylvester stallone
parents
i didn't actually think we would ever
have an episode where both of you were
in the same place at the same time doing
this i know but we are
a good duo aren't we
well we are and we we're crazy glued
together we decided to just wear our
clothes stuck together that's what i
think makes your relationship so special
and interesting to everyone else because
when we reach out to the listeners
asking you know what do you guys want to
know about jennifer and sly 98 of them
were about your love your relationship
yeah how it started how it's going and i
think we should just dive right into it
yeah let's go let's go so i kind of want
to start from the beginning we know how
you guys have met we've talked about on
the show before it's not exactly the
most romantic thing considering you were
at a nightclub
dad thinks it's super romantic even
though i thought it was when a camera is
rolling in a mic's in front of you you
become a totally different person
because i'm a narcissistic exhibition
well someone had to say it wow you
admitted it well of course
all right let's just start
who wants to be an actor
okay
yeah exactly you know why because you
have no talent oh
you put mom into one film and then you
said you you cut me out of the film yeah
let's talk about this i swear i think
you're gorgeous i think you're
intelligent i think you're a brilliant
person
but you are the anti-christ
of acting yeah well that's true okay but
you know no no but i think she's great
she once did a scene where uh she played
a mad nurse and tried yeah but honey
that was in our kitchen and we were just
doing a whole movie that wasn't a real
movie it was a butcher knife
like fake blood well yeah but we're
you're laying on the kitchen kitchen and
then i come back she gives me a heart
transplant and i rise why was this
happening in the first place yeah what a
kitchen because you can't cook no hold
on no no this is so confusing
everybody's like
let me break this down really quick
because i do want to pick up on that
because i think a lot of wives and
people dating movie stars would want
them to put them in the film business
mom is quite the opposite but there was
a moment where you did put her in a
movie and then you cut her from the
movie because she had like one line and
you still cut me
off you were incredible but your one
line was my phone number pretty much
and that's all i wanted to get out of it
did you know that he cut you out until
the day it happened or did you know
immediately
no we were actually watching dailies and
it was goldie and kurt were in the room
and we were all watching them together
what a memory and i remember i remember
it was my scene came up in the dailies
okay i had just started dating her my
character i'm in tango and cash i got
the glasses on i'm driving a convertible
i stop at a light
and then i drive i'm supposed to be
looking at the wall street journal i go
you know
i got a really hard girlfriend i'm going
to put her in the movie
so she comes up on his
stupid bicycle i say just pedal yeah and
i'll be talking to you and all you do is
go
hey but that was so stupid
that's the part i know but that was a
different i wrote it for you especially
that was the worst part i had to go like
this i go
did you and then give them my phone
number
oh no it got more eyeshadows
yeah i said do you own that bike i know
he's asking
i said how many bikes do you own okay
can i ask you i think can you ride a
unicycle yeah excuse me great dialogue
by the way
he was feeding me with the worst
questions so of course it was stupid and
then we were sitting and watching
dailies and everyone thought it was
flirty it had nothing to do with the
movie yeah but it was nice so mom do you
think that you deserve a second chance i
do deserve a second okay okay we've been
together over 30 something years who's
wow so
i think i should have some like little
part not a big part maybe a walk through
okay i got one okay there's this woman
who's out there that she gets she meets
a sea turtle
okay they run away and live happily ever
i love sea turtles anything in the ocean
how about like a like a sea cow maybe a
turtle she loves sea cucumbers
because obviously people listening to
you guys now can see there is very
different a lot of differences between
the two of you guys are polar opposite
but you guys literally cannot live
without one another i think if she was
out of your life with the organizational
skills she has and the town yeah
that i have multiple personalities
what do you think mom does for you and
mom what do you think you do for dad
okay i keep him extremely organized so i
do everything so i do everything from
the minute we wake up to getting him
coffee bringing it to him in bed
bringing him cookies in bed every
morning then going downstairs she
freezes the sky yeah everything yeah you
eat biscotti the oldest man cookie
[Laughter]
i make you breakfast in the morning and
then approaching
everything is great for you for the day
i go through your schedule and then we
you tell a few jokes i laugh
that's what keeps us going because i
laugh and i laugh and i laugh because
he's so damn funny is the funniest man
i've ever met and i'm telling you i've
sat with a lot of really funny comedians
i'm looking at a wall of them here i
want to point one out so i can kill him
i did not so many more
oh my gosh i don't i just aggravate the
hell out of it yeah exactly i've never
done it i don't really know what i do
for her i mean i she knows i would you
know jump in front of a small train
small not bigger
like a choo-choo it would just break
your arms
like a choo-choo little one
i think she's fantastic she's an amazing
woman i tell her that everything she
does i don't know how she holds it
together she's just amazing and she's
yeah
but a little crazy no yeah a little bit
a little bit
coming from someone who's absolutely
nuts that's what i mean a little bit
something had to rub off on you and when
i say crazy good crazy good crazy yeah
yeah there's a difference as opposed to
like sanitarium nuts yeah she'll play a
puzzle yeah in the middle of it yeah can
you play a puzzle you do a puzzle you
build a puzzle right i don't sit there
and play
hey
you think that because mom can sit and
do the same puzzle for six hours
straight without eating anything but six
weeks straight that's true
some dog with his tongue hanging out
like that and a bird i mean it isn't
that you're doing the mona lisa you're
doing wow you're doing cats eating candy
well i have a question that's right what
are you doing and you're well she's
doing puzzling that's more important
you're facetiming your friend i'm just
ready
john you're facing
your friends and you talk about nonsense
that's what the two of you guys are
doing i'm trying to bring together world
peace okay and you're doing puzzles
obviously there's humor between the two
of you you guys can dish and take it
like you guys make fun of each other
what would you say is the most important
part of your relationship that keeps it
young and fun like i mean not a lot of
customers i like this afternoon i think
i think we just don't take it too
seriously
yeah what
oh my god
what are you talking about
oh my god tissue paper it's scary
you don't take it what did i say that
was so wrong no he said we don't take
like insulting
you guys were just throwing insults
really
yeah sly you are the most human being
i've ever met in my life oh dad you're
so sensitive you're the one which is
good no she's
she's really thick skinned yeah she is
she's great and i also i'm worse no no
we have we have fun together and we
we understand each other and we also
it's really important to understand each
other's moods so i know when he's in a
like a funky mood or a bad mood i know
when to like back off or sorry and i
don't go in for the jugular and i don't
like to fight i totally see that and i
think what's really interesting about
your guys's relationship is you mom
don't take anything that he does too
seriously because most things that
dad does is just straight out of humor
pranks he wants to be
you know so controversial in the room
and make everyone have the shock value
but i always hear stories about when you
guys were dating and then early years in
marriage that you used to just torture
her with these horrible pranks all the
time like there was one where you guys
were maybe in aspen or snowing outside
and you locked her outside and she had
only a bathing
i think it was like when we first
started dating so i didn't really know
his sense of humor and he goes oh it's
so beautiful outside jennifer you go
come on you got to see it you got to see
it so come over to the window and i'm in
my bra and underwear and he goes look
look outside opens the door and throws
me out so i'm on the balcony
and people are walking by and i'm in my
bra in underwear in the snow and it's
snowing on me you look so angelic
i swear to you
you were incredible the whole crowd was
out there and going like arthur
it was absolutely like an angel yeah
frozen angel
but the best [ __ ] the popsicle
the day
now you're before back all this horror
uh the day before i go you know this
blonde hair and i think we gotta have a
little
let's mix it up makeover so i walk her
into a wig store oh god and it's like a
really cheesy wig store it's right next
to an ice cream parlor so how good can
it be and i go i'll take that one it was
kind of a short right yeah it was like
kind of a short like cute pixie very
dark
dark joan jones
not john crawford jones joan jett
no not joan j who's the one that was
like joe collins okay like this kind of
thing
so she puts it on and it's a little
large so if you turn your head too
quickly it's just the whole thing shifts
and then there was a bit of a it was a
bit windy that day so we're on so you
know we're walking down the street
no no no no no we're walking down the
street now sly has a crowd following him
right
no
he has a crowd following him and
this is
because there's a through line
what it is the wind came by a bus was it
was very loud
and the wind and it moved her wig so her
part went from here to there like
someone hit her with a hatchet in the
middle of her head
so it's in her face how's it look
it's amazing it's beautiful she's she's
laughing at me the people
watching her head is crooked inside
sideways
and i left it like that
but okay i thought it was so cute
but obviously you guys keep it funny you
can you keep it exciting it's like i
actually you know what dad does for you
a lot is he writes you love letters too
he
me
does
a
he also writes me poems like love not
enough i need to yeah get back into it
shakespeare i have a whole stack of them
i've saved tonight
so mom do you prefer a letter or would
you like flowers instead and do you
think dad is totally down on flowers
he hates
you don't talk about it don't talk about
it
it's like giving someone a bowl of salad
go okay here
these things cost 200 bucks give me 200
bucks keep the flower i guess yeah i
guess sadly they're wait so if you're
trying to excuse me i like i actually
like a plant oh no this one happened to
be plastic but yeah
okay we're trying to save the
environment
okay okay this is gotta go yeah next
week we're having
real cactus we have a question so if
you're trying to woo a girl and a guy is
like okay what do i get her you think
just going up there and giving her 200.
that's going to give her
she's going to be you know what girls
you want to admit it but
someone's going to give you a bunch of
goofy flowers that are going to drop
dead or here's a couple of hundred bucks
you're priming her together that is so
old-school guido yes from like hell's
kitchen like something pretty
so would you say that
dad is more romantic or do you think
you're more romantic i think i was more
romantic in the beginning now he's more
romantic so what did you do for him that
was so reminiscent what happened why did
you fall out of love
yeah what happened oh i get it the
comedian is on the wall
i've never dated a comedian that's
my god she's been with you since she's
not she's had one
so your question was
i what am i well you said you were more
romantic in the beginning i think what
happened was it was it was just us in
the beginning and so i had a lot more
time to you know make them cookies and
dinner
and then you intrusion and then you guys
came along and that and that took up a
lot of my time so every time yeah well
don't you feel like the way that you
guys show love to each other is you
bringing him coffee cookies all that in
the morning because i remember she got
sick recently and i've never seen you so
frazzled in your entire life for not
someone getting you cookies in the
morning
you know what he's like who's making me
breakfast he just said
i said can't you crawl to the kitchen
and get some kids
i got so scared i called them sophia
because we were in florida and she was
they were in la and i got so nervous i'm
thinking oh my god i'm sick who's going
to take care of me so i called up sophia
and i'm like sophia i'm so scared
because it slides here and i i don't
know if you can take care of me no it
doesn't really hey i could take care of
you he was sending me soup from across
the country
i'm sending her all this stuff and dies
if i were what can you think i can help
you're gone looking at cars for the next
four hours you left to go look at cars
all day so it's it's safe to say that
dad you show mom love emotionally
and your humor and the way you speak and
then mom you do the physical things
every single day like carry the luggage
open the door look at the rest
exactly take care of him remind him
about everything
so i'm very age
jennifer was
wagon train material
what i mean by that is you're a woman
that could sit there and go across the
country and defend themselves and forge
a river yeah bake biscuits
yeah
yeah yeah that's true he likes comfort
he does not my idea of camping out
is moving forward one room
that's true actually that's camping yeah
i don't get it he likes lunch
he's very very outside yeah you worry
monsters
mom and dad are from minnesota
how was it you know
here's a real conundrum okay if you're
an outdoors person right you're making
hot dogs milk and then plugging your
thing into a tree whatever electricity
you could find do you see a gnat
like a nat well i don't want to and you
literally will run upstairs naked and
hang from a curtain rod no that's not
not
nothing
actually am i lying it doesn't knock
i have to argue that statement there are
four girls so yes we do all freak out at
the sight of a spider but when i go to
your room and i say someone kill it mom
always kills it do not get out of bed
you wouldn't get out of bed to save
generators
our generator for the pool went off and
just got like a stick or something like
hitting it look like a game fan mom goes
down tinkers it does like you can't fix
it turns on immediately i did i fixed it
i actually have the toolbox in the
family he doesn't he doesn't know what a
hammer is a wrench and uh dare you
just tell them the truth rude i would
love to circle back to the comment that
you guys made before that you said you
were having more fun before we came
along and let's talk about that's true
but now we're actually having a lot of
fun because now we're empty nesters
again so we we are kind of having our
second
second round of fun but i would love to
we're sitting there like a couple of
bald eagles you know where are the eggs
be for yourself baldi well you guys know
you guys have been keeping each other
like very busy like you're always going
out you're working more than i've ever
seen yeah i don't know what's going on
it's great and you have like projects
coming do you want to talk about
projects you have coming up
well yeah
actually we're doing the thing the i
guess the biggest show right now
city well it's now the king of tulsa
called tulsa but that's uh taylor
sheridan who so interesting taylor
showed i knew him before he
sort of made it and he was a horse he's
a real texas guy so anyway he does
yellowstone in 1883 and the mayor of
kingston he's just yeah
so it's so ironic folks that you never
know who you're going to meet right
especially in the barn you know you're
passing people we sold them a horse at
one time actually we sold them with your
horse yeah yeah we saw them your horse
well we used to we used to ride right
next to him so yeah his barn was here
and ours was right next to him and and
he wanted to like you know
i i don't even know if he focused as a
writer but it was a an inborn skill
that's why i've always said with people
sometimes if you fail at one thing that
opens up a door to another for example i
am not
a natural writer i don't like it i don't
write treatments but i can write a
screenplay you've written 45 scripts
i've written a lot of but it doesn't
come naturally it's a grind but that's
that you can see the same for you if
you're a business right like his mom
can't do that because it's the same
thing with mom like mark wasn't
naturally good at building companies but
she's talking about your mother
[Applause]
because you guys are both very very
successful people you're both are still
working today more than you've ever
worked and i think not a lot of people
can handle and balance marriage and work
and you guys were able to do that on top
of also raising kids so how do you think
you guys were able to do that why do you
think you guys wanted to stick what was
the part of work that you needed to have
in the relationship to keep it going i
think
to have a happy marriage
you have to let people follow their
natural inclination some people don't
want to work some people need to work
that was her thing and she's been on her
own since she's 12. yeah pretty much 12
13.
so i thought you know what just let her
go right better
you never you were never intimidated by
me
and it was it was good because i got to
do what i wanted i love my friends i
never got the philosophy no would you
stop in your [ __ ] stop interrupting
her
no
i don't understand why are you finishing
my sentences oh yeah wait let's actually
have a better punchline oh god
no no it's flat it's flattery
oh it is oh you should say thank you mom
thank you oh my god
please have an earthquake
okay
i don't understand when people try to uh
subjugate others and put the lion's paw
on them and not let them do what they
want to do and then you come home and
you wonder why your wife's in a bad mood
so what i mean okay what did you do all
day
nothing i waited for you basically and i
so i just was in my own mind fantasies
of what i could have been who wants that
right yeah i mean so i i think that's
the worst thing is to
stomp on someone's dream you just crush
them
then don't marry her right do you think
that don't marry me don't marry me like
having somebody come back to you was one
of the biggest things that helped our
marriage because i had my own i made my
own money i paid my own bills and i made
i did very well so i didn't i didn't
need sly's money i didn't need to be in
a movie of his i'm not an actress i
didn't i didn't need anything we already
cut we established well yeah but i mean
that's that's very rare in this town
yeah and i think i was one of the only
really
successful early on working women i
think in hollywood yeah you know your
story is incredible and like your work
ethic and where you started and where
you became maybe i'm just speaking for
myself but i think when a lot of women
become mothers that's sort of their
title and it was really important for
you to not only just be a mother a wife
but also a businesswoman so i think
that's really really cool and i love how
you guys um your sort of come up story
from with childhood you both came from
hardships i mean it was not easy in the
slightest for either of you but how did
you guys persevere and find motivation
to become something more of yourself
when all of the odds were stacked
against you i mean like it's so easy to
stay wrapped in the sink hole of i'm
gonna just do what my family does my
brother's done every generation right i
think what you're saying
some people like it just to stay where
they're at and that's that's fine um i
knew i wanted more in life and i knew
that there i didn't i didn't come from
money and i didn't have an education so
i knew i had to work harder and and
learn it and do the best i could do and
i never gave up i tried if one door
closed like i just went through the next
one and the next one so what was your
mindset though i was pretty serious
growing up like i didn't have i didn't i
couldn't it was either sink or swim so i
swam always and a lot of people if they
get rejected or they get a bad time and
i also stayed really true to my soul
like i didn't go out and party a lot i
didn't do drugs i didn't go to
nightclubs i stayed home i got a good
night's sleep i worked
yeah but that's that
i like that bill's character yeah i
totally agree if you're out there
partying drinking doing this stuff
you're never going to be prepared for
your day and you're going to get burnt
out i'm going to get burned out people
are going to get burnt out on you and i
stayed really i i remember even as a
model i never partied with the models
and they all partied and did drugs and
smoked and did coke and did all this
stuff i never did that i would put her
to bed at 9 30 and i would go out
by the way that's true because you are
labeled the king of miami when we grow
up that's such a god no you don't
understand sophia and i will go out and
we have old club promoters saying your
dad the king of my titties will smith
will smith saying i'm singing a song
about how you were the king of miami
that you had an automatic table at every
single place no no they said that you
had a table at every single nightclub in
miami just automatically just by the way
i've never been to a nightclub in miami
i know she never but that's actually
that was hot so now this is where were
you you were in bed at night she was
doing a puzzle that's why it works
because i was going to ask about so you
were very straightener and then
well you knew not but
with the kids you did keep us like that
and i think a lot of people have
questions about how
you were able to raise us and i mean i
feel like people that listen to this
podcast can kind of tell like we're
pretty humble normal and a lot of people
say that uh you're very like how normal
you would be with a family that is so
famous so how do you guys think that you
were able to do that for us really
because it listens on me because i stay
with you guys every night i didn't have
nannies raising you i picked you up from
school every day i dropped you off i
took you to all your sporting events i
me i sat with you with doing homework
every single night and i think that's
really important also i gave you guys
structure structure's everything for a
child if you're a young parent out there
love and structure is what a kid needs
and more than anything else i think too
many times parents want to become like
best friends with their kids just
quality repetition yeah and it's really
important
and i'm the worst
soon as she would leave town i'd say
let's skip school yeah that's true
yeah you don't need to learn anymore
i'll just that would drive me absolutely
but i do have to say even though
you're so a type you would never we
could have the flu and you would still
send us to school we've never been tardy
never got a detention and then we had
dad who sort of was the relaxer if you
will oh yeah but it takes us to school
go to miami
so i remember doing homework you know in
a cigar lounge because i just wouldn't
be in math class and that was also
really fun for us because some of our
best memories are
being able to have parents that are able
to do both because yeah i think that was
really important and i think i don't
know we had a lot of fun it made us i
think it gave us structure because now
we have a really good work ethic because
of you but then we also have a little
oddball
crazy time kind of crazy time
where the giant would live every day oh
yeah forever for the hotel i remember he
used to tell us this hotel was where a
giant lived and i swear to god we
believe why do we believe everything and
then he told us about american idol that
he performed on it not american idol no
my favorite my favorite lie my favorite
lives lies and he still
preaches this today as if it's not total
[ __ ] is you say all of the scenes
that you shot in cliffhanger were real
mountains and cliffs that you were
hanging off of and it wasn't green
that's where you need close-ups and you
can't do that on a real face of a
mountain when you're four or five
thousand feet but you told me you
actually hung thousands of feet above
the ground i did it
no some of it he did do that but like a
mo some of these
uncabled
there's another thing
for a tv show okay
okay that's not a word
okay so i gave old son
how would you though
we'll move on we'll move on from here
how many back operations five five three
neck fusions
everything i've been in the hospital how
many times at least 30. at least i take
out his styles now you think i got that
by doing
nothing
no okay so i'm the only one in your own
stunts hollywood that belongs to all
three men's three stuntmen's
organizations
so not to blow my trumpet the point is
there are certain things no but there's
certain things and when you're designing
the film and this is for people that
make films they understand
you can only do so much on the exterior
when you get into the acting and you
need to have something that's
ridiculously close up
when i'm swinging on the rope with the
girl you can't do that for real on the
side of a cliff it's just physically
impossible and incredibly dangerous so
you have to come in for that welcome
interesting let's wait i have no idea
i'm writing you're right let me ask you
because i'm serious
i have a question because i feel like a
lot of people have this question but i
don't really know how you guys would
answer it how do you know that she was
the one and how did you know that he was
the one how
people form a bond sometimes it's a long
long fuse while we started
we knew each other in high school then
we grew up and then that becomes more of
a friendship and
okay
let's get married so it's not one of
those
so
it wasn't
you know it wasn't one of those things
where i felt when i saw her the first
time i and i it's the only time i've
felt in my life
is whom oh the earth moves
he did he's always said yeah so that was
the first time
yeah the first time i walked into a
restaurant
everything
is just so
don't say it don't say it
large
time
eyes her hair her presence her aura what
do you think i'm talking about your feet
my hands are big yeah
yeah
wait so do you think we i this is then
did you think you had love at first
sight like real 100 wow mom what was
your first impression of dad oh no oh
god i
i was a little nervous because you know
i had i was
young and i didn't she went home with me
that night i didn't
stop i did not anyways i went home with
my friend kirsten that night so like
let's get it right but i fell in love
with him after
a few
months because for me i have to really
get to know somebody to really fall in
love with them and it and i didn't get
that is such hey let her talk this is
her answer
i mean infatuation and i liked it but
love to me was is something you have to
build on i
don't know
you fought like oh my god he's super
cute he's handsome he's funny he's this
and that but love to me is very very
deep and don't i i don't love that many
people and no i know when i fell in love
with them it was like forever i always
say because i mean
like this i don't know if people know
this but you lost your father pretty
young and then you just never had
structure at all in your life and i feel
like that's kind of what you guys
brought like he brought his help
he gave he a literally he's your
protector i mean my dad is literally the
most overprotective true if you say
anyone is bullying you don't trust
anybody he got us gold bracelets no you
got our snacks
don't trust anybody well we can change
it don't trust arithmetic how's that
perfect don't trust army ants
no but i like to say that when you get
into a relationship with someone and why
it works out so well if even if you're
total opposites you guys provide
something for each other and that was
something he probably and i was i was a
very nurturer for him yeah exactly
because he didn't have a lot of
nurturing as a child and i think i came
in because i'm a very soulful nurturing
mothering type of person yeah and i
think he lacked that in his life he
never had that so i came in and gave him
that side because i think a lot of times
people meet him they think oh he's tough
he's rough and he's you know movie star
they also don't see he's also human he
also needs love and he needs to be cared
for and he needs someone that truly
loves him and doesn't you know it wasn't
i need i didn't need an acting part i
didn't need to be famous i didn't need
any of that
i think we just i think that also helped
in our relationship because it wasn't it
wasn't i wasn't there for any other
reason he wasn't there for we just
fit
here is something everyone can relate to
when it comes to money you think about
it obviously differently than your
parents so sophia
let's say we unpack that today it is
time for unfiltered finance presented by
moneyline our parents and us we're in
completely different generations so it's
definitely a generational thing yeah i
feel like i have this problem too but
cece do you remember something that you
wanted to buy that mom and dad were
totally against but you were dying for
it you know every time i see a flash
sale on an online website i'm buying it
fair i'll buy the whole collection i
can't help it i think most of us have
that problem with something yeah and you
know what sofia they're still
still holding it over my head today but
i am lucky because my parents have
educated me on the differences between
gen z's relationship with money versus
their generation for example my parents
saved more for the future while our
generation believes in living more in
the moment like experiences or not
thinking about early marriage or
children that's a huge thing so since
our generations have completely
different values that makes talking
about money with kids much much more
challenging and what about technology
like me and sophia for example we know
what a check is but it's not like it's
the first thing we're reaching for in
our purse in addition there are a
multitude of cards today but we haven't
even scratched the surface to say
crypto right i mean
i can't even get into that i would argue
that affects the way generations can
communicate about money
obviously cece and i were well provided
for we were raised by a great family and
all that stuff and we are very hard
workers even if there's a generational
divide our parents made sure we
understood the most important lessons
when it comes to earning money and they
say that it's important to not spend
money on something that only lasts
temporarily and make sure you start
saving up i i don't know if i agree
entirely with that because i understand
that clothes
are you know temporary happiness but
their happiness in some forms but i see
what they're saying so thank you mom and
dad and you'll be pleased to know that i
am currently seeking help for my online
shopping really and no sofia
it's not healthy of course she's a lost
cause
money
moneyline
i have a new baby
do you want to know its name yeah
athletic greens oh my gosh well you guys
i hope you're enjoying the episode so
far but sophia and i want to take a
quick moment to announce our very new
exciting sponsor athletic greens we are
partnering with them because it's a
product that we started using and loving
because we needed more energy athletic
greens doesn't taste like it's super
healthy because we don't like that
chalky greeny type of thing that's in a
lot of those products it has a kind of
mild tropical taste that you guys can
look forward to in the morning oh
you guys you're gonna taste like you're
in hawaii why not so you're probably
asking what is this stuff with one
delicious scoop of athletic greens
you're absorbing are you ready
75
75 high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system energy focus
recovering aging it goes on and on and
on athletic greens is a lifestyle
friendly so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free
and i don't know if this is important to
you but it's important to me it has less
than one gram of sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial flavoring of any
kind and it still tastes good it
supports better sleep quality and
recovery and also supports mental
clarity and alertness multivitamins are
so important for anyone to take tons of
people take some kind of multivitamin
and it's important to choose one with
high quality ingredients that your body
will actually absorb like athletic
greens athletic greens is a great
company to focus on sustainability they
are a climate neutral certified company
in 2020 they purchase carbon credits
that support projects protecting old
growth rainforest and if that isn't
enough to get you guys already hooked on
this product for every purchase they
donate to organizations helping to get
nutritious food to kids in need
including no kid hungry here in the us
in 2020 athletic greens donated over 1.2
million meals to kids that's amazing so
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
the convenient daily nutrition
especially during the times of flu and
cold season just one scoop with your
water every morning and that is it
there's no need for millions of
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health they make it so easy
so if you want to get in on this amazing
product athletic greens is going to give
you free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
unwaxed again it's athleticgreens.com
unwax so take ownership of your health
and pick up the ultimate daily nutrition
insurance
[Music]
you know how a lot of people are one way
in front of cameras and and just in
public and then behind closed doors
there's something totally different
you guys are the exact same behind
closed doors no yeah
this house
[Applause]
i can't we actually cece and i both say
this when we go to dinner with other
families and their dinners are so quiet
so boring and i i i'm like uncomfortable
because we we don't just talk we yell at
each
people come over to our house and they
never want to leave because they're like
there's something always happening
someone's falling someone's bleeding
someone's screaming crying laughing
laughing
jobs
dogs are eating off the table yeah you
can't leave nothing better you invite
people over for a spaghetti dinner with
no utensils
this is gonna be fun
let's see how this goes and then the dog
jumps in if you go to the bathroom the
dog comes in you do not want to leave
your seat because the dog will jump in
the cat will jump
your hat will drink the water out of all
the waters and then the dog will jump
and eat the remaining food off your
plate it's awful and then dad will take
the leftovers
i like leftovers even after the dog eats
it no he still eats it
that's true that's actually disgusting
let's talk about that for a second yeah
the food that you eat
is
is so alarming like you went through a
phase of only eating buckets of cottage
cheese you went through a phase of only
having celery and celery juice or
snapple or sorbet you said that's a
snack i told my boyfriend at dinner the
other night for some reason you thought
it was a humble brag that you would eat
half a gallon a night of sorbet and
they'd get frostbite yeah and they did
fry spices and they'd sit there with
blankets and towels wrapped around them
and then by the way he got so crazy
about sorbet we were on such a big
sorbet i had to call restaurants and
find out where they got the galaxy
and you would eat out of those yeah i'd
eat with a blanket on well because you
got brains
he would shake
your brain by the way i'd like to get
back
rarely do you get a brain freeze from
ice cream unless it's too cold but
sorbet will kill you i mean that was the
last time oh
i mean you'd be on the floor literally
going oh you heard her here first every
time you come on the podcast we learned
something new sorbet will kill you
he gave himself frostbite like i did i'm
telling you no but yeah you eat some my
lips would be blue but i couldn't stop
but it was a weird thing i think it was
going through a depression no no no i
remember you would eat the same thing
like like psy would eat the same thing
every single year that's my point
chickens
you're an extreme mess
for the audience that wants to stay in
shape
okay here is my theory
when you see a racehorse oh my gosh
strongest beautiful animal what are you
comparing yourself
excuse me am i going to finish this
thought
that's it
clam up they don't have pizza and oh one
night they have spaghetti and then run
the kentucky derby
no
there's consistency they'll have eight
bag of oats they'll have a certain
amount of hay and that's it
period the way down to the ounce so when
i would do films like rambo and i had to
direct them and stay in shape or rocky
which is hard to do
i would eat the same food for five
months which would be a crappy dried
piece of chicken
um something green
and maybe a
fistful of size of brown rice that's it
so i've never developed a love for food
and before that
everything i ate tastes like aluminum
because my mother gave me tv dinners
when it was just starting to come out of
the microwave i lived on tv dinner they
hadn't fresh no there was no microwave
yet there was nothing that was like
cookies so it was an invented cheese
[Applause]
or 1812. if you want to stay the same
size forever eat the same food every day
you know what though well this is such a
good well yeah yeah
but that's a funny no i i have to say i
have to say you you're judging it but
you eat the same food every day yeah
same thing every single day i can't
change it up yeah i'm kind of like you
every day rice cakes almond butter
vegetables every apple yeah and one
brand of granola soda
oats blueberries
right caramel rice cakes i eat
everything in the pot i eat toast cheese
i eat eggs okay is this like a food
it's a food more wait let's get it okay
so we're gonna get into listener
questions we put up a poll on instagram
these are all you have a listener left
now
you're probably right but they wrote it
they've been overloaded they wrote in
and they want to know these things all
right okay first question is for sly do
you like to cook and i'm pretty sure we
just answered that no no i despise god
okay i like cooking up ideas that's a
bad idea next wait hold on you've got to
go like this you've had a booger this
whole time
no
a booger not a
okay you got it it fell yeah it's not
sure don't tell me to flick it
stop
ah
dad did you know stop it
booger
you used to pick me
up listen no it was fine but you used to
put me down when i was younger and stick
your girls
young girls and boys
you don't wait an hour to say someone
has a booger in their nose until they're
hey you want to kiss me tonight i would
except for four hours you've had this
snotsicle hanging from your lips you
bring it up go did you have something to
eat tonight
no no it wasn't even obvious but i just
know it's not even gonna come up but i
don't i didn't notice because it was on
the other notch but i love them
sometimes
i didn't notice
your mother eats like spinach she loves
spinach i hate spinach
everything's stuck
and i will tell her but by the way how
does he circle around back to me i know
it's about you and a burger how do i get
green stuff i don't have anything in my
mind okay
all right can we get the next question
what's your perfect day together
perfect day is like if she's in a good
mood
i think you girls will admit when your
mother gets on a mission
watch out when she's calm it's the best
that's right when you're
but if she's on a mission like we're
going somewhere that's so bad
yes but that means because i have to
take care of everything but how does
this describe a perfect example
good morning
she's fantastic
we're moving on this is surely going to
trigger another fight what are your red
flags in each other so red flag is
something that you just think is so
off-putting for example i would say
sophia's red flag is the amount of
almond butter she eats i don't know yeah
that's a red flag i would say dad's red
flag is that he leaves his used tissues
oh yes that's a red flags
oh did you see that body angle oh you
see that no no no doubt that i'll
describe it no no a red flag is when you
grab your boyfriend's hand and goes
yeah that's a good job
that's a definitely
what does mom do that's a red flag like
what do you what do i do that bugs you
it could be any little character trait
well i can tell if she's
if i'm talking or someone
like looking out the window and being
totally
indifferent it's sort of a red flag okay
okay so mom what's dad's i think
i think i think it's the the tissue
thing when he blows a tissue like
anything blow it too fast
i would say dad's red flag is he uses
kitchen olive oil as lotion and then you
touch everything and the whole kitchen's
oil gross every handle you can't give
them a hug because you get all these
bellies on yourself
honestly mom doesn't have a lot of red
flags yes it
a is flag is every time you eat you have
crumbs all over your chest
okay yeah that's a red flag that's a red
they can't say it in your mouth
i'm embarrassing
so next next question
okay a red flag is when the dog runs
downstairs with your underwear in its
mouth how cool that was sophia mom can't
remember when uh buster takes your
underwear and brings it to his back oh
my god he collects all our things
i'm eating breakfast and all of a sudden
you have what are those things called
a thong
it's next to my omelette
oh
my daughter because everybody loves my
songs
that you're wearing sort of like
bloomers or girls or something like that
why don't we wear blue i just it's my
dream yeah he doesn't know i don't want
to see your daughter wearing dental
floss for underwear first of all you
don't have to see it because you know
what i do but i don't see it the dog
brings it to me
so this is buster's red flag this is no
one else's [ __ ] okay like you
the fact that you see my phone yeah
that's just so gross so bad i'm gonna
lose my mind stop leaving it
it's like in my shoes
he doesn't dress
up
okay next question
mom how did
mom how did you get past dad's ed hardy
face
oh god i think i burned oh man that was
that that was the worst
i hope you show a photo of this ed hardy
fans i apologize for the indifference
okay
i was doing expendables so i find when i
act that i work from the outside in if
you start to change the way you dress
and everyone here will say oh you
totally feel different wearing a suit
than you do wearing this or wearing a
dress and you do that am i wrong
okay so i'm doing expendables he wears
bracelets he has his hands taped he's
wearing leather yeah but i mean i had to
live with that guy i had to live with
whoa yeah you're
yeah but it was like what is it when you
uh what does it call when you act off
and on not that acting and ed hardy
that's what you did was method acting
and i'd heardy well i gotta sleep with
her wearing a sweatsuit what's the
difference
in this wait no i do have to say that
you were an ungodly amount of
rhinestones every day yeah you were
covered in rhinestones and that was just
it was like another red flag
you know what you're never going to get
hit at night tracking power all right
well it's actually true so if you could
describe your relationship with a theme
song what would it be
this is him
yours would be the purple people eater
giant purple people eat it eater
that's your relationship theme song oh
come on yeah
oh gosh what i don't know mine would be
something from puccini's opera la boheme
like nesendorma no it would be the the
russian orchestra with the the bees
[Applause]
and it's like the most chaotic
soundtrack ever yeah that's a hard one i
mean that's like
i don't know you're seeing something
yeah that's kind of a heart we don't
have a theme song yeah like turkey in
the straw is a good one okay so next
question no more okay
lollipop
it's a good chip lollipop this is me
it's too erotic stuff
um okay so how do you guys feel they're
asking about the kids moving out of the
house and now it's just the two of you
on your own i had a nervous breakdown
no did she i did no we miss you guys no
question about it we love being around
you guys i mean i know some parents like
cheer and open champagne
and for me it was really really tough
because i raised you guys so great and
we did such a good job that
now is like the fun time of hanging out
with you guys
and
and now you guys you guys shouldn't have
moved down until you're middle 40s or
30s it's like something but really where
are you going well your boyfriend's home
and lived there for a few years
together in the morning meet in the
kitchen like that's awkward that's weird
it's not why what are you what four
years what
i love you so much
that was like
good morning girl
leave me alone leave me alone
leave me alone
no i think that's like the hardest thing
is because we actually love being around
you guys that it's hard when you guys
move out because we really miss you so
much well we missed you too except when
you gang up that's a bad
oh my gosh next question okay one thing
the one you now have we're a team of
women we gotta stick together so you're
an odd man out so you and bob buster
need to go smoke a cigarette yeah he
does love taking dye's cigars so yeah
okay next question who was the difficult
child to raise
controversy
oh scarlet that's true no no question
about it you know a daughter is going to
be hard when you guys are afraid of a
nat and the other one has a tarantula
sitting on her head yeah yes she would
wrap herself in my line bella concerned
put a snake around her neck and had the
train she always just did what she
wanted
what was your first date and how did sly
ask jennifer out okay this is our first
date and i'm going to go really quickly
because it's a long date
we had a mutual friend invited me to go
to a restaurant invited to go to a
restaurant but he invited way too many
girls
i think we rode horses we went to hidden
valley and i left
our first date with no no during the day
buy this shirt i understand but the
first date day we went guys
yeah so romantic yeah we both love
horses and um i knew how to score power
oh my god he actually is yeah you got a
really good thing he does give great
dating
because i like doing stupid humans yeah
no kidding yeah but anyways we rode we
had a great day riding horses that was
our first official that's really cute
okay i love that um
what is the best lesson your daughters
have taught you i think the best lessons
is that
you don't realize how much
you can love somebody i don't know if
that's that's not a lesson i don't but
honey i think for her
it's for me
you can't it's there's no button
sorry time's up
you're so mean to her
like let me finish my thoughts the best
lesson is
you realize that health is wealth and
when your kids are healthy and happy
you're good because you can only be as
happy as your most unhappy child that's
something yeah saying something like
that anyway you're being crushed by the
cliche tank
i like that so much
i like it no no no what was your lesson
with having all the girls your mother is
the best she's great
to learn i don't i think uh wow i don't
know
probably to be a bit more contemporary
in other words you bring me into a
different generation
music wise which
but it's different it's different
different different you when you look at
politics and everything else i think
it's i also like uh
watching your
well sort of weird you're dating life
yeah that's it's very interesting
because they bring home so many creeps
oh my god no i don't know what was the
last time i brought someone i'm joking
again can you guys
i was going to agree with you we don't
like you you brought home
the thing is you hate having your
daughters uh you know just be out of
your sight once they get a car license
and every parent will tell you this is
one of the worst days of your life when
they start to drive am i wrong no it's
terrifying and i always imposed a curfew
sorry
but curfew
and i call you man right
that's true our curfew was so strict at
10 o'clock at night and if we weren't we
couldn't be in the car at 10 o'clock if
we were not i go where the hell are you
go in the shower downstairs yeah
literally if we weren't in the kitchen
or in our bed we were in oh and he would
stay up and he would wall hours
trouble when i saw your silhouette
no see because you're you always like to
backlight yourself yeah for everything
and so i just see you on the second
floor balcony looking down and i'm like
like i bring a lighting crew guys let me
i remember dad you're so dramatic you're
not going to put the light on in the
bathroom it's behind you you can't well
obviously i don't need a proper ring
light to make your body i walk around
like a with a wind machine yeah
i remember the amount of times i'd be
driving 15 minutes away from the house
and you're like where are you i'm like
oh i'm just walking in
just to get you to go to bed oh i need
to worry about it because it's just a
very yeah it's true that's true sly what
was your least favorite movie to act in
and mom what was your least favorite
movie he's acted in um
just one answer creed two that was your
least favorite to act in why whoa long
story okay okay but that's one and uh
that's not for it because it was just a
bad time i realized rocky was ending
just like it was very emotional
and
lovely
see i liked oscar oscar was just i think
it was called french farce which is
weird comedy and the audience just but
it's really well-made i thought it was
funny yeah i'm sure yeah i thought it
was kind of funny uh the one that would
turn out to be the biggest
disappointment
which because i loved working with her
was rhinestone basically lost
in the middle and each director had a
different interpretation so
we lost it i didn't remind you
what was your favorite or least favorite
film that dad said i think it was like
stopping my mom will shoot was trinity
that was so bad that was so bad
or or what was the one and i hated it
because you were too like dark oh you
know what i'm just gonna hate it because
i love it
oh is it the travis is it the judge no
it's the killer it's no you get carter
well i still think you're acting piqued
when you were the toy maker and spy kids
oh
funny you bring that up it's my favorite
i finally got to play four characters
middle schoolers when that movie came
out and we were walking around i did
that for you guys actually he did do it
for you really yeah because he thought
it would be cool that could also
so which of your three daughters this is
me hard do you trust the most to least
trust me i can't even say that i don't
know why you asked that you write that
down that's a pretty hard question no
who do you trust the most and who do you
trust it doesn't have to be serious not
serious like who would tell a fan you're
not going to fight in the car later who
would i trust scarlett you can't trust
me
no she always she everything's a half
church she spins it no she's like
they're all god that's a tough one i
know and that's not fair i feel like
we're kind of people it depends yeah
like sometimes you get really
me high strung yeah you really like what
am i lying no she's doing right
you get really snappy and then you then
she gets very emotional you explode oh
yeah yeah
it gets explosive so i get very
passionate in my fights and then i
exploded
wait then we all explode
that's so much fun but no i trust you
all with my life so
okay so this is the last question
hardest lesson you want to keep going i
want to do it take me home tonight all
right you know what i'll switch up the
last question i miss eddie money baby
where you been buddy
dad last question can you sing a love
ballad to mom right now yeah do it
as time goes on
so you guys this was probably actually
this is my favorite episode i'm just
saying that now and it will be because i
think now everyone has got to see the
other side of us yeah it's never been
really seen before well my message to
you is when in doubt shout out my
message is let it loss every day okay
perfect then we're signing out lost the
one you love thank you guys so much for
watching this very special episode of
the unwaxed podcast we will see you next
tuesday bye guys bye keep watching
[Music]
you